[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
week feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today I'm joined in
studio by Bo beep Bobby Ray what's going
on man so the new album psychedelic
thoughts be on the lookout for that do
you know how the show works I've seen it
I saw it mg K's some Machine Gun Kelly a
little bit of toner yo-yos a little bit
of Tony Yayo so you know how it goes we
have 10 questions 10 wings as we move
along in the interview the wings get
hotter the sauces get hotter the
questions get hotter so hot in fact that
you might just have to throw in the
towel you say the safe word I'm a [ __ ]
bought it and then that means that you
can stop max go right to the last
question but there's a catch blah what's
it if you make it all the way through we
give you 30 uninterrupted seconds to
plug away if you don't make it through
I'm gonna take half of your ready man
I'm ready
all right Bo be there you're hot
so this first one Texas Pete's just
basically innocently in every American
home yeah you're not really gonna find
us in Texas Pete so I was watching some
of the vlogs that you've been putting
out some for me this album is a lot
about reintroducing people to so who
Bobby is who b.o.b is and I noticed that
you shooting yourself with that point of
view point of view thing are you one of
those [ __ ] guys that is just
snapchatting all the time one of those
people you can't even have a
conversation with because they're just
firing off their phone non-stop no that
is not me but I'll tell you who is who
it my manager be rich is it snapchats
himself snapchatting you snapchatting
something else
snapchat inception he can't even talk to
him because he's snapchatting you have
to snapchat him to talk to him alright
Tallulah hot sauce Tallulah to me
doesn't count as hot sauce I mean this
is like no but this is like they call it
hot sauce but it's not it's
garden-variety stuff no big deal I can't
have you on without talking about
eggplant Friday basically it was this
thing where people would put a Mayfair
filter on the Bulge of their sweatpants
put it up on Instagram and then that was
like your eggplant Friday now see mine
there was no filter involved just a just
a hashtag no filter bulge back it was
just so you know up I was in the kitchen
checking my phone and somebody happened
to snap a pic and I was like man this is
a nice picture I think we should post
this so flattering one in the lead image
on basically every media outlet that
covered it was your eggplant Friday
picture
yeah I wonder on some level were you a
little bit proud of that because I think
I would be definitely I mean to start a
trend that got banned you know people to
get around with it and you know the
hashtag just became this became corrupt
yeah gotta control its art into porn all
right so this next one is oh you can't
Echo Caribbean habanero another one
it's like you know right now we're just
shooting free-throws nothing crazy
yes I may need to pay as Oh who's taking
the shots per your request we went with
winglets for you we wellness bonus for
you and I'm going classic wings mm-hmm
interesting choice at first I was like
maybe that's like a performance enhancer
like maybe that's unfair that he's
boneless but I think it's gonna work
against you yeah work against me what
cuz you just got it you gotta eat one
wing that way and like your bite my bite
is gonna be half hot sauce half white
meat your bite is gonna be three
quarters hot sauce shots plate is your
girlfriend seven Streeters she featured
on the new album she is alright so you
know a lot of people think that Jay
mailed in his verse on drunken love and
it made me think about when you
collaborate with someone who you're
seeing okay so let's say seven gets in
the booth for a track that's gonna be on
your album and let's say it's a little
man do you talk to her about it do you
talk to her in a way that's different
than maybe wouldn't another artist do
you let it slide no we don't know yes
man ISM going on at all nobody's yes man
if it's you know because I work we're
both professional like we both taking we
do very seriously so okay if I'm doing
something man it's not good there's
gonna be like she gonna let you know oh
yeah
she's not no no she won't go like this
there's a talk man while I'm in the
booth I thought you might say she's I
think I just try to cut that again make
that better
so this one is the lattes hot pepper
sauce laddie laddie got like a little
bit naughty yeah exactly
you gonna cause trouble we don't bother
nobody you know so far these have been
pretty pain you know all sauce but no
high you're not the first person to walk
in here and be like yeah why this come
by the end everyone's chugging water and
milk men watch I noticed that you like
to cook yeah if you were in a cook-off
with Action Bronson
Raekwon the chef do you think you'd have
a shot of winning man I've seen action
birds and do some cooked up some pretty
crazy stuff he does some next-level
stuff he does some he's going to heights
that I have not yet gone before as a
chef in my chef ISM so I don't know man
it might be he might he might take the
outcomes taking place all right so this
next one is paint is good Louisiana
style it's really kind of the last of
these gimmies this way I don't I don't
need a disclaimer I just you know just
show me what a ring is your career is
kind of interesting in that you've
probably been to like every music award
show which one has the best after
parties I'm definitely gonna say the
EMA's absolutely is that the European
yes what is it about those parties that
separates I got the most shit-faced I
ever got in my life and this is when I
met Chris Rock you know here Rock sorry
spices [ __ ] with my head
alright so nut Kid Rock not Chris Rock
yeah so I mean he taught at a bar even
though we have a couple of drinks and um
so he had another after party like an
after-after-party in his penthouse
so I'm sitting around talking and
I said a little about my music what I do
it you know he hit hurt anyway and you
gotta win so I told my play guitar he
was like don't play guitar yeah he's
like oh yeah guitar yeah so I was like
man yeah yeah you know I was at this
point I was already like kind of
shit-faced yeah yeah I play guitar get
it starts okay Rocco somebody get a
guitar so couple a couple moments passed
by someone brings a guitar and so I
played letters from Vietnam this song I
was writing but it wasn't out yet
I play letters from Vietnam then he
looks like he grabs the guitar and shows
me up it starts playing the [ __ ]
guitar with a Jim Beam bottle and if I
can just start a little blown guitar off
with Kid Rock the Kid Rock knows how to
[ __ ] party I don't doubt that if I
was an you're see nobody party hard so
now we're at pain 100% hot sauce and
this is where the game changes
all right
gun play 2.0 over here pokerface then
poof - salmon press would be an
understatement
[ __ ] you'll be over here I like spicy
foods over so it's like it goes outside
of your mouth and curls back around onto
your face and here's then your mouth
becomes your whole face become spicy and
it follows you around it's like a scary
movie - you know what I mean like you're
not gonna escape it it's gonna just be
it follow-ups hey you know what else you
like smoking weed and you know what I
wonder what's your what's your go-to
snack well say when I get high I'm not
trying to cook the same but I will I'm
the gas station guy what's your are you
a chips guy or you a candy guy both I'm
not supposed to be not supposed to mean
no you got a diet no I've seen you
you're you're working out hard and
you're doing like the overhead press and
you're doing cardio and [ __ ] like whoa I
like workout yeah it's like the trot no
joke I'm the tricep strength there we're
up to what do we 7 which is Blair's
original death sauce
who's the spicy one
you shared the studio space with Iggy
Azalea when she was like fresh off the
plane from Australia right I wonder do
you think that the things that are said
about her are unfair do you think that
she's unfairly targeted in any way or
he's big he's always been a tough cookie
I mean she's always been like a real
honest person when you meet her funny
things that stands out about her is the
fact that she's so vocal like she
doesn't have a future so she speaks her
mind so you know no matter what anybody
goes through man ultimately you're in
control but you can you can overcome
anything whatever type of obstacles
somebody or people may want you to they
want you to believe what they want you
to believe you know I mean it's like
it's like they say hi look at you hi
look at you
hi look at you to the point you believe
it but it's like anybody can overcome
you know they're faced with are you
cruising cruising yeah number eight
oh god you got a little shaky I had a
really Becky this one's about twice as
how does the one we just had this is
Dave's temporary insanity Hot Sauce
Atlanta you know the strip club scene
two plays such an integral role in the
music that comes out of Atlanta you know
a lot of Records break in those spots
less talked about but just as important
is the role that strip clubs in Atlanta
play in the culinary scene there
particularly with the Wayans and I'm
wondering which Atlanta strip club has
the best food everybody in Atlanta knows
that cheetahs has the best food there
pitching like won awards and she got you
know white linen you know and the seats
are like you know real sturdy leather
seats it's like a real you know except
for strip club real restaurant except
naked window they stare up titties
alright so once again with David was the
hot song Amy's board man once again
we're with Dave's but we lose the
temporary part of the title this is
Dave's insanity
hot sauce thirty-six times hotter than a
jalapeno book I feel like for some
reason [ __ ] somebody get real real right
now I know it's coming
Wow when the heat you is like it's like
an even aced it's like you go numb for a
quick seconds and then it's like but not
in a good way not a good way don't think
about it - did you think you're in the
clear there's no vision and then it
really opens those glands up what's the
best advice you've ever received vti
everybody's not wrong it's a reflection
of yourself you know what I mean like
everybody says something and and you're
seeing it if you're seeing something a
constant denominator in several
situations like it's not the outside and
world that is doing you wrong it's you
internally personally like you know I
mean you can look at it that way - so we
have a little tradition at hot ones
where we dab up the last oh [ __ ] how
long is this tradition been going like
today it actually started with your be a
machine gun Kelly okay I can't even
remember I think he might have suggested
it actually but basically you just got a
and there's a lot at stake on this poor
because it'll it'll sneak up on ya so
are you gonna be one of those dabbers
are you gonna like what you're gonna so
get you [ __ ] with like ah like I think
you mostly smoke blunts but do you ever
[ __ ] with like edibles or dabs you ever
do in miniature
I have seasonal asthma
in the springtime I can't smoke wax I
can't I can't just [ __ ] spots me up
just a touch there you go perfect
perfect pour so this is mad dog 357 hot
sauce the king of the mountain seventy
one point four times hotter than a
jalapeno the test of manhood
are you ready man yes boy struggling a
little bit man because I know what to
expect no [ __ ] sucks alright ready
why are useful things
Markel meeting is past for some reason I
think it's like gets it over quicker but
somebody talk to me that's what we
eating is faster alignment you're doing
good
so it's kind of tasty you bought your
life you like matching your head happens
every episode watching news help me take
my mind off the spice
nothing you got fresh puddle though it's
a facade I don't even believe you so the
new album
shake it out thoughts got Bob wood
coming up Bob wood fish whoo I've seen
you at the custom guitar then the
bandana wrap what's going on with the
jimi hendrix thing or do you just get
into some strong acid or something a
little bit of both no I'm just joking
I've never really
I didn't mean to ask it like that I
wonder if this is like actually
dangerous like you've never consulted a
doctor or anything you've gums start to
bleed consult a physician it is kind of
rip we kind of referenced the Jimi
Hendrix album cover it was really
supposed to be a painting just for me to
have so fast forward a year later I
start recording psychedelic thoughts
back and forth is like the lead single
I'm like man I want to make a body of
work for this song back and forth and I
was recording my album and songs like
[ __ ] it might be it'll be dope so you
know just put out a project for all my
friends if you're not if you're not a
day one be able be Fanta you don't
understand what people say when they say
anymore Bobby right this is what they're
talking about
there we go and congratulations he made
it all the way through killed those
wings Wow how was it was it went worse
than you expected it better
like you beat the [ __ ] out of those
sauces never seen anything like I've
never heard that before anyway
you beat the [ __ ] out of these sauces
but you really did there's no other way
to describe it and then the floor is
yours
congratulations on making it through 30
seconds thank you I respect it I respect
it you came up there look the floor is
yours that camera right there 30 seconds
BAM what's up y'all this BL beat Bobby
Ray Bans nation i'ma pick up my new
album psychedelic thoughts on iTunes
streaming wherever you can find it
SoundCloud Spotify my name is Bob I
approve this message I'm goin bad
Oh
pjk Mike no no still not used to it
being legal here I feel sketchy yeah
that's like [ __ ] the ring and it reminds
me some Christmas [ __ ] people say blood
guys have big dicks is that true yes